welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
boss in the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special establishes one big new
rule for the MCU as we look ahead to
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. no matter
how much Peter Quill Mrs Gamora he
should not definitely definitely not
Rebound with mantis and this video is
sponsored by rage Shadow Legends we'll
give you some more info on them in a
moment as many of us speculated after
Guardians Volume 2 mantis is a half
sibling to Peter Quill both of them
children of ego since ego was
technically a Celestial in the MCU on
the same power tier celestials like
erishim and tiama from the eternals this
confirmation may also change the balance
of power but rarely brings up deeper
questions about these characters genetic
histories I'm gonna break down this
ancestry to find out who's been
smooching who and why none of them have
been me in the Guardians holiday special
we learned for sure that Peter Quill and
mantis are both children of ego mantis
initially shares this secret with Drax
because of you know my
the one only you know that your cool
sister
and in the final scene finally shares
this with Peter Quill who accepts it her
Father Peter
he might be ego you might be what he is
my father too
wait does that make you my sister
that's the greatest Christmas gift I
could ever get
and yes this confirms with many of us
speculated since Guardians Volume 2 that
mantis was another one of the Unlucky
offspring of the countless mates that
ego hooked up with trying to breed a
child who would carry his Celestial
genes and when his Tableau shows the
dozens of smooches one of those Maids on
the far left is the same species as
mantis implying this must have been
mantis's mother and mantis is Peter's
half-sister now when I'm not inhaling
movies and TV shows I love exploring new
worlds and collecting every last thing
there is to find and when I'm out and
about the best way to do that is with
worry Shadow Legends with over 600
Champions to collect an upgrade endless
artifacts Define and billions of
different teams to try out right Shadow
Legends has years of content let's open
some sharks to get some new Champions I
got a Boga from a sacred Shard he's a
great support Champion that will be
helpful in hydrating dungeon battles not
as much luck with my ancient shards
those are all rare Champs that I'm gonna
sacrifice to level up with better chance
like bogot and I also got a blood braid
ooh nothing personal I'm also gonna
sacrifice because I'm going all in on
bogoth this month is huge for raid they
just released a brand new faction this
Sylvan Watchers was amazing new
Champions forced elves and Druids days
the vibe is very Rivendell raids also
got a full lineup of events along with
the new season of the forge pass where
you can get your hands on some of the
most powerful gear the game has ever
seen and if you're an Amazon Prime
member you can get your exclusive
rewards in raid right now and if you
click the link in the description or
scan the QR code here on screen you get
unique bonuses worth thirty dollars a
free champion Rector draft 200 000
silver one energy refill and one XP
boost and one ancient Shard so you can
summon awesome Champions as soon as you
get in game all of this stretcher will
be waiting for you right here treasure
now sometime after Volume 2 came out a
social media post from actress Jennifer
sharp began to recirculate in which
shark posted a photo of herself on set
for Guardians Volume 2 with a since
deleted caption claiming she shot the
scene as mantis's mom with Kurt Russell
but the scene got removed from the film
James Gunn at that time responded with
another photo of sharp with Kurt Russell
but at the time he downplayed any
familial connection between Peter Quill
and mantis and said that fans quote
don't necessarily need to infer anything
else in the this information now all
this is coming from articles that came
out at the time citing guns tweets and
replies and likes on other fans tweets
to him but now that the Guardians
holiday specials come out and now looks
like gun was definitely playing Coy when
he was denying Peter and mantis's
Connection in this scene with ego and
mantis's mom was truly part of Gunn's
conception for mantis's origin ego
killed all the other Offspring and piled
up their courses on a cavern on his
planetary body but he kept mantis alive
because she has the ability to sense
emotions and relax someone into a
dormant State ego used her to ease his
mind during his search but I mostly use
it to help my master sleep he lies awake
at night thinking about his progeny now
at first glance it would seem that
mantis joining theater is a fellow
offspring of a Celestial is a huge deal
his response that them being related is
the greatest Christmas Gift Anyone could
get might be his way of saying well
great now we got another Celestial kid
to help take down these that could also
explain why Peter Paul was so eager to
set up shop in nowhere and buy it from
The Collector because nowhere is a
severed head of a Celestial formerly
used to mine Celestial brain matter
Peter could want to study the inner
workings of a Celestial so we better
know it's how to pop open one of these
skulls and battle in the future but not
so fast while mantis is the child of
celestial ego made a point in volume 2
that none of his offsprings except for
Peter Quill carry the celestial genes
one after the other they failed me not
one of them carried the celestial genes
until you Peter out of all my spawn only
you carried the connection to the light
so Peter Quill was unique in carrying
the celestial genes mantis did not carry
them if she did Ego search would have
ended way earlier and he'd have no need
for Peter Quill to fuel his expansion
because he would have mantis to do it
ego only kept mantis around to keep him
company and to help ease his mind which
is a pretty cruel role for her and an
essential function for him basically he
needed her to offload all of his guilt
through her impact Powers she had to
carry around all of his guilt for him so
that he didn't have to so this would
suggest that whatever made Peter Quill
unique to carry ego Celestial Gene
whereas all of his other half siblings
couldn't that quality actually came from
his mother Meredith will America well
remember it's certainly at the heart of
the mystery Easter egg that James Gunn
has said isn't fully found even if
videos like ours have gotten close the
recent season of Shield brought up that
question of who Captain America Steve
Rogers lost his virginity to and the
best answer we came up with was that fam
girl played by Laura haddock the same
actress who plays Meredith will in the
Guardians movies implying that Captain
America might be related to Peter Quill
this fangirl was the one woman Steve
clearly had a connection with a camera
bulb flashing on them giving
photographic evidence of this encounter
so that others in the future like Bruce
Banner would be able to confirm this
independently and that war bonds tour
stop was in Chicago the closest on the
tour to the quill family Homeland in
Missouri so I think there's enough to
speculate here that this woman could
have been related to Peter Quill maybe
his grandmother or great-grandmother
really he's married as well would have
been born in the late 50s so this fan
girl would have to bear a kid who then
had another kid who then as a teenager
would have another kid we gotta sandwich
the generations here to make this work
James Gunn was asked about this theory
in the past and he has gone from
jokingly confirming it to as recently as
this August tweeting that the timeline
makes it tough but he did respond sure
why not to whether this band girl could
be Peter Quill's great aunt and sure why
not is a lot more than that flat out
denial that mantis and Peter Quill were
related I think this starts to explain
the recurring confusion over how mutants
work in the MCU exactly black panther
we're kind of forever formally declared
Neymar is mutant but didn't really
explain what made him a mutant or how
that connects him with others of mutant
kind like Kamala Khan Neymar was born to
a woman who was pregnant when she
consumed the Yucatan variant
heart-shaped herb and he was born
underwater with winged feet pointed ears
and the ability to breathe both
underwater and on land through skin
diffusion all of this was a unique side
effect for neymore no other telekineal
can do everything he can so was it
because of side effects while he was in
utero probably not Neymar's mom was
pretty far along at that point so
whatever that baby was going to be was
already in his DNA I'll admit I'm not an
OB GYN they won't let me but I don't
think the MCU is about to say if [ __ ]
happens to you when you're pregnant your
baby comes out of mutant we need less
confusion around the pregnancy process
right now not more okay to that end
let's hope Blade's origin story doesn't
come from his mommy bit by a vampire
when she was pregnant marble Studios you
aren't allowed to change that rather
people are mutants because they have a
genetic predisposition an X Gene
something they are conceived with so
that when life events like puberty or
external exposures occur things that
happen to everyone or mutants it
activates other things in their DNA her
name or that baby always had the X Gene
for the moment of conception but then
after that while he was a fetus when his
mother drank that potion that activated
the mutant Gene that was already in his
blood while he was still in the womb so
that he came out the way that he did now
what does all this have to do with Peter
Quill and mantis well something about
Peter's genetics from his mother made
him uniquely capable of handling the
celestial genes and surviving things
like the infinity stone radiation and
according to erisham and eternals ersham
deliberately designed eternals as
sterile synthazoids who could never bear
children making them in his own image
celestials do not procreate sexually
they have one and only one procreation
process implanting Celestial seeds in
planets ego as a Celestial tried to find
a loophole to that rule and it didn't
not work until Peter will so by that
logic Peter Quill must be a deviation or
a mutation to the celestial's divine
plan so it's Peter Quill a mutant in the
MCU I don't know but we are about to
learn a lot more about his genetics in
this guardian's holiday special
established this key relationship with
his half-sister mantis to help him
explore that connection let me know your
thoughts down below you can follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you